I think traditionally in New York
politicians wait until after they're
elected to get indicted I've already
been there so I'm saving the voters time
and money hi I'm Nick Gillespie for
reason TV and today we're interviewing
Kristin Davis who is running for
governor of New York Kristen thanks for
joining us thanks for having me what is
your platform my platform is the
legalization of marijuana prostitution
and legalization of gay marriage what
are the benefits of legalizing pot
legalizing gay marriage legalizing
prostitution well I think first and
foremost the economic benefits are
something that we need to address in New
York or broke we definitely need a plan
to bring in new revenues no other
politician is putting forward any plan
to bring in new revenues other than
increasing taxes so you know with the
legalization of marijuana it's estimated
to be a 10 billion dollar a year
industry if we legalize regulate and tax
it we'd be looking at about 2 billion
dollars in new revenues which is
something we desperately need what why
is why is it so difficult to legalize
pot or prostitution I mean their vices
you know there's a stigma associated
with each each being different and
socially not acceptable and you know
however these underground businesses are
occurring anyways it's common sense that
we look at legalizing them taxing them
you kind of got injected into politics
not really by choice can you talk a
little bit about how you came to public
light sure you're correct they came to
public light and not by choice obviously
most people you know are not aware
particularly that no one really wants to
make the cover of the newspapers for
being arrested you know I was sitting in
Rikers Island arrested for promoting
prostitution in association with a sting
on former Governor Eliot Spitzer and saw
myself on the cover of the newspapers
you are you
the madam of the escort service he was
using right I was a madam ova and one of
the agencies that he was using correct
what what is the benefit to working
girls legalizing prostitution there's a
ton of benefits you know it will
decrease sex trafficking sex workers
needs need rights you know traditionally
the women are always punished men never
go to jail the women end up in jail once
they're labeled as a prostitute with a
felony or misdemeanor record their
unemployable so they are forced back
into this lifestyle where the men can
they're never punished charges are never
brought against them obviously evidence
against Switzer no charges were brought
against in and they go back to their
normal lives and it's a is it a sad
statement or a great statement on the
state of New York politics that if you
became governor you would be succeeding
Eliot Spitzer and David Paterson we
would finally have an honest person in
all finally have an honest person I
think traditionally in New York
politicians wait until after they're
elected to get indicted I've already
been there so I'm saving the voters time
and money how does gay marriage
legalizing gay marriage or recognizing
gay marriage fit into this into your
platform well I think my overall
platform is based on personal and
economic freedom so I think you know gay
marriage is a matter of equality it's
unconstitutional that person cannot
marry whoever they choose so what about
you know the naysayer say well what
about group marriage then would that be
okay um I think there has to be some
sort of limit you know but it's not an
issue that I'm put thought into your
also as you're running for governor and
you'll be collecting signatures in July
and whatnot you're also creating a
reality TV show can you talk a little
bit about that um we're creating madam
governor with the intent of promoting a
libertarian agenda bringing some
awareness to these issues and hopefully
becoming agent of change in New York and
maybe globally do you think is this a
good time to be libertarian
or is it you know I mean on the one hand
every government is broke they've over
reached on the other hand they seem to
be more powerful than ever I actually
think it's a great time to be a
libertarian I think we should learn
something from all of our fallen public
officials they all make you know a ton
of promises and then when they get into
office they break every single one of
them career politicians only care about
re-election and the special interest
groups that they promise things too so I
think that it's time that we talked to
some normal people about you know how we
can you know better enable our state
well I want to thank you good luck with
the race reason of course is nonpartisan
and we don't endorse candidates but I
suspect that our readers or audience
will find your platform particularly
attractive Thank You Kristin Davis for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie